it damned again it's even darker
oh it dimmed like mad hey guys this is
vadim with max tech and right here in
front of me
i have the brand new 2021 m1 ipad pro
right here
with eight gigs of ram and the 2020 ipad
pro with the a12z chip
with six gigs of ram and in this video
i'm going to answer a very important
question
which one of these is better for gaming
especially since there were a lot of
people online complaining about the
m1 chip in the new model draining a lot
of battery life so
in this video what i'm going to do is
play a full hour of call of duty mobile
and ginshin
impact on both of these ipad pros and as
you can see i've set the brightness to
100
to basically put as much stress as
possible on both of these
to see if the m1 chip does heat up more
and cause the display to dam down and as
you guys already know the performance is
crazy for example in geekbench 5 the m1
ipad pro is
53 faster in both single core
and multi-core performance and then in
the metal graphics test
it's 81 faster 95
faster in geekbench ml and then in
wildlife extreme
it's 48 faster but both of these have
the same
battery sizes so it's gonna be very
interesting to see
which one it drains more all right guys
here we are on the m1 and as you can see
it is 10
46 right now so an hour from now we're
gonna stop this test
and then switch over to the a12z the
first game we're gonna play
is call of duty mobile i have my xbox
wireless controller right here so let's
get right into it now the really crappy
thing about having the m1 chip
is that sometimes software is not
optimized for example you cannot do
very high graphics quality and max frame
rate at the same time
it forces you down a high that is
ridiculous but we're gonna turn on these
other settings real time shadows ragdoll
anti-aliasing
and we're gonna make sure to match them
on the a12 z model
as well so let's get started try me
try me yeah yeah
got him all right let's go up here
got him let's go behind oh
come on got him
yeah oh yes
yay spray and pray bro
oh i saw that so far in call of duty
there has been no dimming whatsoever
even though i'm at 100 brightness and
the performance has been basically
perfect as you would expect
got him
boom oh i tried to jump
oh there you go that was easy i love
that
oh through the wall got him
got him
no way 50 to 15.
guys look at that kill cam i almost
reloaded but i didn't
that was good look at that score guys 27
kills
zero deaths i didn't lose oh that's
crazy man
alright guys so it's been about 30
minutes playing call of duty mobile on
the m1 ipad pro
so i'm going to continue playing gentian
impact but you guys are going to go into
the future and switch to the a12z ipad
pro
playing cod mobile i'm in the settings
and this is really weird
because the 2020 ipad pro with the a12z
has an ultra frame rate setting it says
mp only i wonder if that is 120fps that
would be insane
but for the purposes of battery life
we're going to set it to exactly the
same that we had
all right here we go now with the a12z
chip we didn't have any issues in the
past
everything worked perfectly fine but i'm
interested to see
if you're going to get better battery
life with the 2020 model
got him watch this what's this
got him
where you at got it
don't even worry man
i got you too don't worry
yes i got that kill cam right boys
got him all right what's going on
whoa whoa
hi dude hi
run past everyone
oh come on
[Music]
all right just like with the m1 we're
getting perfect performance
no drop frames or nothing no dimming so
far all right guys it's been
30 minutes playing cod on the a12z 2020
ipad pro
so let's go ahead and go to genchin
impact but you guys
are going to go on to the m1 alright
we're back on the m1
playing some genshin impact we're in the
graphics settings and it shows that
we're overclocked
pretty sure i set everything to the
highest let's just
max everything out here unfortunately we
can't do 120 fps we can only do 60 on
here but that's fine
i just want to see if we can dim this
display with genshin because
it usually does game looks pretty good
so far
boom gotti all right there you go
boom gone with the wind
got him i'm honestly surprised guys
because i've been playing
at maximum brightness for a while i'm
not noticing
any dimming can you watch this what's
this what's this guys
boom oh no 10 hp i got this
wait did it dim hold up i feel like it
dimmed look
i'm trying to raise it higher but it's
not only like at this level
it starts to drop feel like it did dim
guys
it did dim a little bit right there i
noticed it got a little bit darker
it is not able to get higher than this
interesting all right guys there you
guys go 11 46 as you can see right there
on the m1 ipad pro
and checking the battery life we're at
71 battery life
after a full hour of gameplay call of
duty mobile and gentian impact
i don't know if that's good or not so
let's finish off with the a12z
2020 ipad pro right here we are in the
settings
on the a12z2020 ipad pro
set everything to as high as we can this
is weird because i've just maxed
everything out but the current
performance load is balanced
which is weird because on the m1 it said
overclocked so i don't know what's going
on probably some kind of software stuff
anime guy wait
wait wait wait did it just dim the
display just guys i literally just
started
genting impact i think it dimmed let's
check all right so you see it's maxed
out but
look see that it's not getting any
brighter at this point
i don't know what's that like 90 90
something percent
it's not changing that means the a12z
dimmed and it did it a lot faster
sooner so i think that the cooling
system on the m1 is much improved and i
think apple
it damned again it's even darker
what in the world the weird thing is now
that
the dimming happened i am noticing a
little bit of dropped frames every now
and then just
kind of glitches up i didn't really
experience that
on the m1 yeah guys it is quite a bit
dim let's see
let's test out this dimming all the way
to around this level that's like i don't
know
less than 80 percent that should not be
happening that's not fun
so one thing to keep in mind guys when
we look at the battery life
this one should actually be doing better
because the clock speeds are turned down
and the brightness is turned down
oh watch this this can be messed up boom
rami oh
oh it dimmed like mad it's actually hard
for me to see the display i cannot
believe it guys
the a12z continues to dim
this is the third time the a12z chip and
the 2020 ipad pro is dimming
and it is dimming like crazy i cannot
believe this
less than 50 see i am so impressed by
the cooling system in the m1 alright
guys it is now
101 exactly an hour on the a12z
this is the moment of truth let's check
out the battery life seventy percent
one percent lower than the m1 ipad pro
after an hour that's crazy even though
this dimmed by a lot in the performance
was compromised
alright so there you guys go that was
one hour of gameplay
on both the m1 and the a12z ipad pro
now let's get into my conclusion well in
call of duty mobile there was basically
no difference at all
there was no dimming no performance
issues both did a very good
job but then in gentian impact
the m1 did an excellent job only dimming
a little bit
maybe down to 90 brightness but on the
a12z
almost like right after i started
playing it dimmed down
and then after a little bit it dimmed
out even more and then later it went
down to like 50
brightness it kept overheating now on
top of that let's talk about those
battery life numbers
after a full hour the m1 was at 71
percent but the a12z 2020 ipad pro was
at 70 so it did
even worse in terms of battery life even
though
the display was dimming a lot so it
technically should be using less battery
life and i think the clock speeds
were being throttled as well because i
was having performance
issues i've got to say guys i'm
impressed
with the m1 ipad pro so my conclusion
for this entire video
is if you're thinking of buying a brand
new ipad pro
you should definitely be spending the
extra money on a brand new m1 instead of
finding one of these used because for
gaming
it's definitely the better choice the
better tablet even if you can get this
for a better deal so
we're gonna have links to the best deals
on these ipad pros down in the comment
section below
and if you enjoyed this video go ahead
and click the circle about to subscribe
for more videos like this one definitely
check out one of those two right there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]